und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka kann
abends morgen abend um diese zeit werden
wir die wahlergebnisse von sachsen
anhalt bereits umfänglich durchleuchtet
haben
zwei fragen stehen im vordergrund wie
geht das rennen zwischen cdu und afd aus
und welche regierungskoalition sind
möglich im moment regiert ja kenia viele
in der cdu würden künftig aber lieber
die fdp an bord haben die liberalen
könnten ist diesmal auch in den landtag
schaffen und ständen mutmaßlich freudig
bereit
es kann aber auch noch ganz anders
ausgehen ministerpräsident haseloff hat
klar gesagt dass für ihn eine koalition
mit der in teilen extremistischen afd
nicht in frage kommt das sehen
allerdings nicht alle in seiner
landespartei so wie sich der
wahlkampfabschluss heute gestaltete hat
andreas weise beobachtet am ende sieht
es doch noch fast wie ein normaler
wahlkampf aus die parteien werden mit
ständen in der magdeburger innenstadt um
letzte stimmen mit dabei ex schwimm
weltmeisterin antje buschschulte für die
grünen
ich habe keine ganz schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht und die alten hasen
in unserer partei sagen dieser wahlkampf
war eigentlich weniger aggressiv als die
davor endspurt nicht nur in den
innenstädten ein ungewöhnlicher ein
pandemie geprägter wahlkampf die zu ende
dann zählt man merkt viel abstand wie
die leute auf einen reagiert zug fährt
der partei ministerpräsident und
spitzenkandidat reiner haseloff die cdu
will stärkste kraft bleiben setzt im
wahlkampf voll auf ihn dass der reale
kontakt zum wähler mangelware war stört
haseloff kam
wir haben viele schalten gemacht sodass
also durchaus auch personen mit dabei
waren die man sonst gar nicht erreicht
hatte die sich auf dem marktplatz zeigen
auf der anderen seite war auch die
qualität der diskussion und der dialoge
auch ganz ganz anders
oftmals hat man ja dann doch störer
dabei trotz corona die afg ging von
anfang an auf die marktplätze
wahlkampfabschluss in magdeburg ca 250
teilnehmer und fast genauso viele
gegendemonstranten egal wie stark die
afg wird regieren will mit ihr niemand
man kann auch so politik machen
wenn man das nicht anders schafft ja
aber das wollen die leute ihn nicht die
leute wollen hier mal verantwortung von
zwei konservativen kräften
inwiefern das hier link versehen doch
weder bei der cdu noch anderen gelten
sie als konservativ oder gar
koalitionsfähig der linken einst
lauteste protest stimme des ostens
drohen weitere stimmenverluste trotzdem
spitzenkandidatin von angern kämpft vor
allem mit zwei themen bis zuletzt eine
wird die ungerechtigkeiten zwischen ost
west die wir ja sehr provokant
angesprochen haben und das andere ist
die situation unserer krankenhäuser
wir sagen ganz klar hier müssen
krankenhäuser wieder in staatlicher hand
zurück es war ein wahlkampf mit viel
bundesprominenz bei allen parteien auch
bei der spd
10,6 prozent vor fünf jahren tiefpunkt
in sachsen-anhalt trotzdem regierte die
spd dann weiter mit in der schwarz rot
grünen sogenannten kenia koalition und
will dass auch weiterhin investitionen
nach der krise auch in unsere
gesundheitssysteme ins krankenhaus
mit einem gesetz das für gute löhne
sorgt so wie wir es mit dem
tariftreuegesetz vorhaben und das thema
schule und bildung das prinzip sehr
vielen menschen auf den nägeln
die dritte kenia partei die
bündnisgrünen setzen voll auf
klimaschutz
wir kämpfen dafür drittstärkste kraft zu
werden ich glaube dass es möglich in
diesem land wo sich immer mehr menschen
für klimaschutz interessieren und es ist
auch wichtig weil das ist die große
zukunftsaufgabe und das muss ein
stärkeres gewicht in der nächsten
landesregierung haben ob die grünen aber
in der landesregierung bleiben ist offen
laut letzten umfragen könnte es die fdp
nach zehn jahren wieder ins
sachsen-anhaltische parlament schaffen
und so für mehr koalitionsmöglichkeiten
sorgen auch wenn sachsen anhalt nur
knapp zwei millionen wahlberechtigte hat
es ist trotzdem der letzte stimmungstest
vor der bundestagswahl und aus unions
sicht könnte die stimmung besser sein
der masken skandal den einige
unions-abgeordnete ausgelöst haben sitzt
die in den knochen und jetzt muss ich
gesundheitsminister sparen auch noch
fragen lassen ob er tatsächlich
mutmaßlich minderwertige ffp zwei masken
obdachlosen und hartz4 empfängern
unterjubeln wollte sein ministerium
weist die vorwürfe zurück
in wahlkampfzeiten stürzt sich der
politische gegner aber natürlich
trotzdem darauf am meisten unter druck
aber steht armin laschet die sachsen
anhalt wahl ist die erste seit er
kanzlerkandidat ist viel helfen wird
dort auch nicht dass ihnen heute seine
landesparteien nrw bei der wahl zum
spitzenkandidaten nochmal rückhalt gab
alcoa mwst
minute langer applaus für armin laschet
so sieht begeisterung bei der cdu auf
97,5 prozent der nrw delegierten
stimmten für ihn
der kanzlerkandidat gibt sich in seiner
rede kämpferisch sein ziel ist klar ich
will der nächste bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland werden und
dafür kämpfen wir da wirklich um eure
unterstützung
laschet bekommt rückenwind durch seinen
landesverband ein wichtiger
stimmungstest morgen die landtagswahl in
sachsen-anhalt sie schwebt über allem
die wahl laschets ist da schnell
abgehakt schauen natürlich mit großer
spannung auf die wahl in sachsen anhalt
dort gibt es ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen
zwischen cdu und fdp und wir kämpfen um
jede stimme kämpfen um das vertrauen der
menschen mit reiner haseloff der sehr
viel unterstützung bei den menschen hat
der generalsekretär ist einer der
wenigen die sich äußern wollen
der masken skandal des
bundesgesundheitsministers sorgt für
unruhe
dazu die landtagswahl das hemmt die
gewohnte gesprächig kite friedrich merz
ralph brinkhaus und jens spahn halten
sich heute vor der kamera lieber zurück
laschet gibt für die landtagswahl morgen
eine klare richtung vor
wir verhandeln nicht mit der afd
wir kooperieren nicht mit der fdp
koalieren nicht mit der afd
und wir werden sie bekämpfen und der der
der beste garant dafür ist ist reiner
haseloff
im umgang mit der afg wird sich zeigen
wie geschlossen die partei wirklich ist
die nrw cdu jedenfalls hat ihren
spitzenkandidaten den rücken gestärkt
und jetzt den nachrichteninhalt wolf in
der jahrelangen diskussion über eine
weltweite mindeststeuer für
großunternehmen gibt es eine wichtige
einigung die finanzminister der g7
länder verständigten sich bei einer
konferenz in london auf eine globale
steuer reform zu den zentralen punkten
zählt eine mindeststeuer in höhe von 15
prozent und das prinzip dass
großkonzerne dort steuern zahlen wo sie
ihre umsätze machen
bundesfinanzminister scholz sprach von
einer steuer revolution auf die synagoge
von ulm ist offenbar ein brandanschlag
verübt worden
der staatsschutz wurde in die
ermittlungen eingeschaltet ein zeuge
hatte beobachtet wie ein unbekannter an
der fassade flüssigkeit ausschüttete und
anzündete
der schaden blieb gering weil die
feuerwehr die flammen schnell löschen
konnte
ministerpräsident kretschmann
verurteilte die tat als heimtückischen
gesicht des antisemitismus und jetzt der
blick auf die aktuellen corona zahlen
das robert koch institut meldet 2294
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 3132 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 122 todesfälle kamen innerhalb
eines tages hinzu die bundesweite sieben
tage incident sinkt auf 26,3 die zahlen
jedenfalls was neuinfektionen angeht
sind ja wirklich erfreulich da kann man
mit optimismus in den sommer gehen nur
hoffentlich bleibt das auch so
beim blick nach großbritannien kann man
durchaus dunkle wolken am horizont
aufziehen sehen zumindest aber
fragezeichen
die indische variante genannt delta am
zeigt dort was sie drauf hat
nach dem was man bisher weiß ist sehr
wohl deutlich ansteckender und nur die
erst and funk reicht nicht um sie in
schach zu halten erst hat der zweiten
spritze sehen die ergebnisse besser aus
geologen warnen
wenn's gut läuft könnte die delta
variante auch in deutschland zu einer
vierten welle führen
vor allem im herbst mit schulen voller
ungeimpfter kinder wie die situation in
großbritannien eingeschätzt wird
berichtet unser korrespondent andreas
stamm bitte reinkommen und zwar schnell
überall im land wie hier in gloucester
werden zweite impftermine vorgezogen das
tempo nochmal erhöhen um den nächsten
gegner in schach zu halten die zuerst in
indien nachgewiesene delta variante ein
wettlauf die schlange am mittag vor
einem impfzentrum in london wo sich
erstmals studenten impfen lassen dürfen
spricht bände
wir alle wollen diese krankheit
loswerden das normale leben zurück haben
die masken wegwerfen
doch delta könnte zum spielverderber
mutieren die nun dominante variante im
königreich wohl mindestens 50 prozent an
stecken da noch fehlen genügend daten
die gibt es bei den fallzahlen es geht
in einigen regionen steil nach oben
die einschränkungen werden gerade
relativ schnell aufgehoben
premierminister johnson beharrt auf dem
21 juni als tag an dem die pandemie
endet alles wieder normal sein wird ein
großer teil bevölkerung ist noch nicht
vollständig geimpft wir sehen gerade die
sich die dritte welle auf baut die
hälfte der erwachsenen briten sind
zweifach geimpft erst das gebe
ausreichend schutz gegen delta zeigen
erste studien wissenschaftler beugen
sich über die daten streiten sind
genügend geimpft gibt es genügend
genesene mit aktiver immunabwehr um die
drohende del tabelle zu brechen werden
viel weniger menschen ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert im vergleich zu den
vorherigen wellen die die eingewiesen
werden sind jünger enten selten auch auf
der intensivstation es sieht gut aus
dass die impfstoffe den kreislauf von
infektionen krankenhauseinweisungen und
tod unterbrechen können
es wäre ein fehler
am 21 juni als tag der öffnung
festzuhalten
wir haben in den vergangenen 15 monaten
schmerzhaft erfahren spät handeln heißt
oft zu spät
die forscher uneins die politik ebenso
der gesundheitsminister beim bäume
pflanzen für die korona toten er mahnt
zur vorsicht doch sein boss weil noch
nicht vom groß angekündigten tag der
freiheit abrücken dann könnte ich
bislang nicht erkennen warum wir nicht
am 21 juni öffnen können aber wir müssen
vorsichtig sein
auf gar keinen fall wolle man öffnungs
schritte zurück nehmen was die aller
vorsichtigsten fordern die kommenden
zwei wochen dürften entscheidend sein ob
der großartige britische sommer ins
wasser fällt oder nicht ob die nächste
virus welle kommt eine welle die dann
auch wieder auf den kontinent schwappen
könnte nach europa nach deutschland zu
sport deutschlands eishockey team hat
den einzug ins wm-finale in riga
verpasst die mannschaft verlor im
halbfinale gegen titelverteidiger
finnland mit 1 2 bitter enttäuscht nach
ganz starker leistung deutschland
startet extrem schwungvoll nach seiner
und caron verpasst aber auch reichel die
führung ganz knapp dann jedoch die kalte
dusche
die titelverteidiger mit der ersten
zwingenden torchancen und schon führt
finnland mit 10 14 minute deutschlands
moral indes ungebrochen moritz sei damit
der ausgleichschance doch statt 1 1
steht es nur 30 sekunden später 2005
inland die dreimaligen weltmeister
gnadenlos effektiv auch im zweiten
drittel mehr chancen für deutschland in
überzahl zahlt sich das aus der
anschlusstreffer zum 2 1 matthias
plachta 32 minute
das schlussdrittel ein einziger
sturmlauf die deutschen glauben bis
zuletzt ans finale chancen im überfluss
doch es soll einfach nicht klappen
statt endspiel gegen kanada morgen also
spiel um bronze gegen die usa
nach alexander zverev hat auch jan
lennard struff bei den french open das
achtelfinale erreicht struff gewann sein
drittrundenspiel gegen den spanier
carlos alcaraz philipp kohlschreiber ist
dagegen ausgeschieden
bei den finalen ging es heute in zwei
sportarten um deutsche meistertitel die
in tokio erstmals zum olympischen
programm gehören im speed klettern holte
sich franziska ritter aus wuppertal den
titel zum dritten mal nacheinander und
beim trial bike in wurde weltmeister
dominik oswald mit dem 20 zoll rad
deutscher meister und jetzt die
lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
5 14 31 35 44 47 superzahl 1 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf laut zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 es gibt
eine unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor heftigem starkregen
für teile bayerns und die
wetteraussichten für morgen es bilden
sich erneut schwere gewitter mit
schwerpunkt im südosten deutschlands
dabei kommt es zu heftigem starkregen
hagel und sturmböen an der ostsee
scheint die sonne und es bleibt trocken
bei höchsten temperaturen zwischen 16
und 28 grad
in den nächsten tagen bekommen wir
weiterhin blitz und donner verbunden mit
heftigen regengüssen 18 bis 28 grad
das war es von uns gleich vor die
sportstudio doku über yoga kimmig und
seinem weg an die weltspitze und um 0
uhr gibt es die nächste heute express
hat uns morgen wieder biss dann wieder
sind
[Musik]